I did more for the black community
than anybody with the possible
exception of Abraham Lincoln.
All men and women were created by
(stuttering) you know the thing.
Is it any wonder that neither Joe Biden
nor Donald Trump can crack fifty percent
in approval ratings?
They're cringeinducing to everyone except
hardcore partisans.
Why the hell would I take
a test? Are you a joke?
No religion, no anything.
Hurt the Bible, hurt God.
Which is why just 31% of Americans
identify as Democrats and
only 26% as Republicans.
41% say they're politically independent.
The major parties are selling Americans
on policy bundles that are utterly inane.
If you want tax cuts, you
have to vote against abortion,
in favor of billions more
in military spending,
and against immigration.
If you want to vote in
favor of immigration,
you have to also sign on to
a $2 trillion Green New Deal,
trapping children in
failing school districts,
and massive tax hikes.
It's no surprise that
typical American voters
are looking more and more
like Bridget Phetasy,
a podcaster and comedian who has written
the battle cry of the politically homeless
and explained in a recent column
why she won't be voting at all this fall.
Her reasons? If Trump
wins, America will burn.
And if Trump loses, America will burn.
The thing that drives me crazy is just
the blatant lying, it's the same thing.
And I'm at the point
where I'm not even sure.
Does he know he's lying?
I couldn't even listen to him speak.
With Biden, I feel terror.
You know, I feel like
Oh God, when's he going to
lose his train of thought?
And I feel like I can see
that terror in his eyes
when all of sudden he hits
kind of a blank patch.
Phetasy is typical of Americans
in that she's socially
liberal on many issues.
I do believe it's empowering
to be able to sleep
with whomever you want.
And conservative on others.
I just like, laugh at the fact
that we're having conversations
about, serious debates about
whether girls and boys are different.
And aware more generally of the limits
of her own expertise.
Then I just stopped and realized
I knew absolutely nothing about guns.
I didn't how to load a gun, hold a gun.
I didn't know any of our
gun laws in California.
I knew nothing. And I was
just spouting my mouth off
as if I did.
She's neither Republican red
nor Democrat blue, but an alienated mix.
Oh yeah, I'm totally a purple person.
I really try to take everything
on a casebycase basis.
She also hates how politics has become
all about shutting down dialogue
and dwelling on resentment.
What I've seen on the left
is just a complete inability
to sooth the cognitive
dissonance that happened
when Trump won the election.
And instead of accepting
what is and moving forward,
and saying, how can we
rebuild, what did we do wrong?
They doubled down, called
even more people racist,
lost more allies, alienated more people
who should be allies in this,
and closed the tent even more.
There's identity politics
on the right as well,
and there's a lot of grievance that I see.
Unless Democrats and Republicans
start speaking to people like Phetasy,
their ranks will keep shrinking
and they'll have to eke
out narrow victories
based on scaring voters
with insane claims.
If you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump,
then you ain't black.
If I don't win the election,
China will own the United States.
You're going to have to
learn to speak Chinese.
Politics needs the same
diversity of offerings
that the internet has
brought to the media.
Bridget!
[Bridget Phetasy] Heyo.
[Interviewer] You're here. You made it.
I came to make a citizen's arrest.
What I'm hearing from people basically
is that they're done with
the mainstream media.
So I don't know how much
longer the mainstream media has
because they behave like
New Media doesn't exist.
They act like the internet doesn't exist.
I see all of these things,
even just my inbox,
with all of these thoughtful messages
of why they migrated politically
and what that story is,
whether it's from red to blue
or blue to red, or independent.
I would say I see a lot of potential
and I see a lot of reasons to be hopeful.
And there's so much conversation
happening in the middle.
I do believe that although
we might have to choose
or people feel they have
to choose in this binary,
that the center is not only holding
but kind of coalescing in weird ways
that might not really be apparent
until after this election.